bonsoir monsieur prévost bonsoir
monsieur loi vous avez dit c'est comme
si on avait dérobé la joconde au louvre
à paris pour l'avait remplacé par un
parent faut le sait c'est quelque chose
qui est quand même important à vos yeux
ben en fait c'est presque incroyable je
dois vous et que quand j'ai appris la
nouvelle je pensais que c'était un
canular alors j'ai communiqué avec le
château laurier qui ont confirmé la
nouvelle à là on a un arsène lupin
en ville parce que l'on vient
d'apprendre que le vol ne s'est pas
produit au cours des derniers jours
étaient derniers mois c'est presque un
crime eux a fait ou on voit qu'on
regarde pas très attentivement les
oeuvres les fameuses photographies de
cash ou la ville en attrister c'est
digne d'un film et c'est vrai que dans
une nature lma dans une autre mesure
c'est comme si le louvre on venait de
découvrir que on a volé la mona lisa la
joconde mais que personne s'en n'est à
faire si l'on parle de plusieurs mois
alors c'est encore plus incroyable
bon ce prêt vous dites moi cette photo
ce portrait remarquable de winston
churchill de cash d'abord redonner mois
le contexte a été fait cas et combien ça
vaut une photo originale comme ça
bon alors que ça était petit décembre
1941 à l'amendé à au coeur que de la
seconde guerre mondiale churchill qui le
premier ministre du royaume uni est allé
à washington parce qu'il voulait avoir
l'appui du président des états unis les
etats-unis ne sont pas encore en guerre
et après il est venu au canada il est
venu à ottawa pour rencontrer le premier
ministre de l'époque mackenzie king et
le canada est un des principaux alliés
lauture à voyons muni alors il est
invité à la chambre des communes et
après on demande à monsieur si on
pouvait prendre une photo et celle là
mais pas au départ mais finalement c'est
youssouf cash qui a pris la photo et
c'est une photo unique parce que on voit
que monsieur chercheurs est de très
mauvaise humeur faudrait qu'ils ne riez
pas souvent mais là il est
particulièrement bourgon c'est parce que
juste avant de prendre de la photo cash
lui a enlevé son cigare et là on voit à
quel point à il est mécontent et cash
lui même a dit que cette photo-là de
changer sa vie puisque il va devenir que
célèbre il va devenir un photographe
portraitiste de réputation
internationale
et quand les grandes personnalités les
rois les reines les chefs d'état hinch
stein par exemple même le pape jean paul
2 rené lévesque alors quand on venait à
tahoua bien il y avait une tradition
l'on allait se faire photographier par
cash et ça peut valoir combien
pour un archiviste comme moi un
historien ça n'a pas de valeur puisque
ça fait partie de notre histoire de
notre patrimoine et c'est très lié à ici
à l'histoire du château puisque kacha
eut son studio la panne un 18 ans il a
habité même au château laurier avec sa
seconde épouse alors pas une valeur
historique patrimonial mais spécialistes
c'est que si on tente de vendre
cette photo
aux enchères ça pourrait aller à environ
50 mille dollars à la sauce et la valeur
monétaire de la photo mais la valeur
historique et patrimoniale
elle est inestimable
et toute cette histoire va faire en plus
augmenter la valeur que de cette photo
depuis 1992 on ne peut plus la
reproduire depuis que cacher fermer ses
studios il ya plus de droits de
reproduction et 7 faudra les adhérents
produit très souvent alors et les gens
se disent maxi hauteur de copies ou
encore s'en fait en moins c'est
l'original alors qu'at on a cédé
finalement quand bak bibliothèque et
archives canada a acquis la collection
se fondent archives extraordinaire on
cherche des originaux pas des photos pas
des copies on va suivre ça je vous
remercie beaucoup de ce cours d'histoire
sur cette remarquable photo qui trônait
au château laurier à ottawa merci nous
avons parlé mais j'espère qu'on va la
retrouver on s'en reparlera très bien au
revoir